It's called descending dungeon,
Cow.
What is that number or would you like to guess you don't have a clue if you want
to describe a moderately large number Brady you'd describe it as
writing a tower of numbers. For instance,
you might write two to three to the four to the five,
and that's not a very big number, but it's big enough.
There is different ways to interpret it.
Do you mean two to the three to the four to the
five?
Or do we mean two to the three to the four to the five like that?
So there are two different ways. Parenthesizes it?
From the top down or from the bottom up. And if you do it from the bottom up,
the tower essentially collapses two cubed is eight.
So we would have eight to the fourth to the fifth,
but eight to the fourth is two to the 12. And to the fifth,
this is two to the 60. So this is about 10 to the 18.
It's big, but it's not very big now. Whereas if we do it from the top down,
this is the official way to do it for one of the five is two to the
10th, which is one Oh two, four.
So we have three to them,
one over two for two to that power. Now, three to the one Oh two,
four is pretty big. So this is two to the 10 to the four 89.
And that's a pretty big number.
So for InstaSizing from the top down,
that's the default in most computer languages. Okay.
So this gives you some pretty big numbers. On the other hand, my good friend,
Mark, LeBron had an idea. He said, um, instead of having towers,
let's have Dungeons, let's go down. He says,
we're going to use the following notation, which actually is in common use.
I'll let a sub B mean read a base
B. And we do that all the time. For instance,
in binary notation seven is one, one, one.
So you would write one, one, one sub two, which means interpret one,
one, one in base two is equal to seven in base 10.
And the way you read this, you say, all right, that one is a one.
That one is a two. And that one is a four.
So this is four plus two plus one,
which is indeed seven. So that's the notation. Now,
if a had just one digit, it's kind of boring.
If we took three sub 17,
it's just three in 10 single digit numbers.
Don't change under this operation. So the first interesting number is 10,
and we're going to rebase it in base 11.
And we're going to rebase that in base 12 and rebase that in 13
and go for a while down to end steps and stop.
What do get, what are these numbers? Well, again,
you have to decide how to parenthesize it,
there are two ways from the top or from the bottom. And in this case,
parenthesizes it from the bottom up is the best 10, seven 11. For example,
just to get started. What does 10 sub 11? Well,
that one means 11 and that zero means you've got zero digits.
So it's 11. Okay. What about tens of 11 sub 12?
What we're going to parenthesize from the bottom up.
So that's 10 now, 11 rebased to base 12.
That one means 12. And that one means one. So 12 plus one is 13.
So that's 10 sub 13. That tends to be 13. That one means 13.
And that zero means you don't have any more digits to add. Okay.
Now what about tens of 11 sub 12, seven, 13. And again,
we put in the Perkins. Well, so it's 10 sub 11,
12 sub 13. What's that? That one is 13 plus two.
Um, uh, dollars is 15. So that's 1115,
but now what is 11 sub 15? Well,
that one is a 15 is worth $15. That one is worth $1.
So that's 16 and 10 sub 16 is 16.
So the sequence that we getting starts with 10, and then we get 11,
13 and 16. Let's do another one.
So 10 sub 11, 12, 13, 14,
13. So 14 is 14 plus three. It's 17.
Okay.
12 sub 17 is 17.
Plus two is 19.
Now we have 11 sub 19,
11 of 19. That one is 19.
That one is makes 20. So that's 20.
And then we have 10 sub 20, which is equal to 20.
So the next term in the sequence is 20 and we keep going.
And the question is, how big do these numbers grow? Well,
we could also have parenthesized it.
Let me show you what it looks like if we do it the other way round from top
down 10, and then we have 10 sub 11. Well, that's 11 again.
Now we have tens of 11 sub 12,
but I'm going to put the parentheses around the top two. So 10,
so 11 is 11, 11 sub 12 is,
um, 13, again, same as it was here. 10, 11,
12 subs, 13 with Perrins likes this.
So this is equal to 11 sub 12,
which is 13, some 13.
That one means $13. That three means three single dollars.
So we get 60. Well, that's what we got before,
but soon hits can change.
If we parenthesize these Dungeons from the bottom up,
we get one sequence, 10, 11, 13, 16, 20,
and then the next one is 25. After 25,
we get 31 38 and 46 and so on.
And then it slowly increases as you can see. And after a while,
it starts to get bigger and bigger and bigger.
And after we've gone to a hundred or so steps,
we're starting to get some pretty big numbers. Whereas on the other hand,
if we print InstaSize from the top down, we get much,
much bigger numbers very quickly from the top down,
it grows really quickly. Yeah. Okay. We get the sequence 10, 11, 13, 20,
so far as degrees, but then we get 30, 48,
76, 132, 420. And so on.
And after a mere 30 steps,
we're getting gigantic numbers as you can see here.
So that's the second sequence. Where are you taking this next? Well,
I want to give you two more, which is the other way,
natural way to make a dungeon. If you give me a bit of paper,
I'll show you in this sequence,
we're going to start with 10 and then we'll do 11 sub 10,
12 sub 11, sub 10, 13 sub 12, seven, 11 sub 10,
and so on. And again, we have to decide which way to parenthesize it.
And the preferred way is from the bottom up.
So 11 sub 10 is that one means $10.
And that one means one more dollar. So this is a level.
So now we're going to do a 12 sub 11 sub 10. Now 11 sub 10,
as we just saw is 11. So what we have is 12 sub 11, 12, seven,
11 is 11 plus two, which is 13. So,
so the sequences goes 10, 11, 13.
Now we have to do 13 sub 12 sub 11 subtext. Okay.
13 sub 13, by what we just did.
And that's 13 plus three is 60.
And that is obviously by what we just did. 14 sub 16,
which is 20. Now.
We will do one more, 15.
14, 13, 12, 11, 10.
By what we know from the previous little calculation is 15 sub
20, but that one means $20 and add $5.
So that's $25. Okay. So that's, that's from the bottom up.
If we do it from the top down, we'll get a different sequence.
This was pretty easy because we didn't have to recalculate everything.
Each time we could just use what we knew from the previous step,
from the difficulty with top-down is that you have to redo the computation at
each step. That's why the other one is preferred. All right.
So 11 sub 10 is certainly 11. Now we have a 12 sub 11 sub 10.
Now 12 sub 11 is 13.
So this is 13 sub 10, which is 13.
And you can see that it's the same. So far, we are 10, 11, 13,
13, 12, 11,
10 is equal to parenthesized from the top
down 13 sub 12 is 12 plus three is 15,
15, so 11 is 16. So,
and then 16 sub 10 is 16.
Still the same as we had before 14, 13, 12, 11,
10, 14, 13 is 17. 17,
12 is 19, 19 seven.
11 is equal to 2020 sub
10 is 20 Holy cow. All right,
we'll go. One more step.
Breaking from the pack. Now we've got a different secret.
And this again, presumably the same thing will happen here, but the one.
It's the same. I have the same pictures as I showed you. Okay?
So now we've got four sequences for InstaSize from the top down from the bottom
up. Yes. The question is, how big are these now?
What happens if you go down a dungeon and steps down towards the
basement? What, how big is the number? If you have a number,
you take its logarithm. It's much smaller than it.
If you take the log of the log as the number, it gets really tiny.
And if you take the log as the log is the log,
it has to be a pretty big number before you get anything.
There's anything that's left after you take logs. So with a tower,
a tower of height,
N you have to take logs and minus one times to bring it down
to earth. But these Dungeons, they don't grow that fast,
which is really surprising.
What you get is that you only have to take logs twice before you get a number.
You can see.
But some of those numbers you showed me like after you've done,
hundreds of steps were massive, logging them twice.
Wouldn't bring you down to a reasonable.
Yes, it does. Um, this is our some tonically yeah.
Um, a hundred steps. We got a number that,
that was that big tend to they're 80. If we were taking logs to the base,
10 of a number like 10 to the 80 10 to the power,
80 take logs becomes 80 times. Log of 10, call it 80,
take the log again. Log of 80 is just under two.
So it drops down very quickly.
But I'm not surprised it has a different behavior because you're doing a
completely different operation with the towers.
You were like multiplying numbers,
but this operation you were doing with the Dungeons involved,
like converting numbers into faces and things that was a whole different game
you were playing. Yeah.
You're absolutely right. Brady.
I may be was exaggerating a bit. Yes.
I mean, they do grow very quickly and it is surprising when you work them out.
You sort of those, those how rapidly they grow those numbers.
See them initially, we thought that they would grow just like towers.
So it was really a surprise to find out that they don't one really nice
example. We've been talking about the notation, Acer B,
which means take the number a and read it as if it was written in base B.
What if you took a and read it in base a and read
that in base say, and you went all the way to infinity.
And in particular, I want to take a, to be the number 1.1.
We'd like to thank brilliant for supporting this video.
Brilliant is a huge archive of puzzles,
quizzes courses, including the course,
as you're seeing on the screen at the moment.
And these are just a selection of them. There are more all the time,
obviously being bit of a number file. The number theory.
One is one of my favorites. This is just a little tiny,
tiny taste of what it looks like. If you're trying to get your body in shape,
you're probably going to join a gym. You might even get a personal trainer.
If you're really serious about it. If you're trying to get your brain in shape,
why don't you use brilliant as your personal trainer with all these interactive
puzzles and quizzes? It's fantastic. It's good. Fun.
And it makes you smarter go to brilliant.org/number file to
have a look. And if you use the slash number file,
they'll know you came from here and you'll get 20% off.
If you sign up to their premium subscription,
that's the subscription that gives you access to everything.
Thanks to brilliant for supporting this episode.
Five means five over 10,
the six means six over 10 squared.
If we take 1.1 sub itself forever.